good morning hello and howdy from San
Antonio Texas we're very happy you all
have joined us this morning for the live
webinar titled rodent surgery aseptic
technique made easy
I'm mr. warm of the University of Texas
San Antonio and I'll be moderating the
session today's educational seminar it's
presented by libraries the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific learning to learn
more please visit WIC
you can post questions to the speaker
during the presentation while the fresh
in your mind to do so simply type them
into the QA box which will open when you
click on the green Q&A box at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation everybody see the Q&A box
good to enlarge the slide window click
on the screen icon in the lower right
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing during the presentation just
click on the support button found the
top right of the presentation window or
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and that's offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on this CD
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Marcel purr
a genteel of the University of Texas San
Antonio
thank you mate for the introduction get
this email from let me call an
investigator professor Jones do not say
the name and it's an email that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not be found anywhere in the u.s. lab it
is all kinds of cross-contamination the
individual tumors produce adjusting
glasses
Matt or haze and this and that and the
other so I say well this is the division
and he wants to defend his program and
he brings data and he indicates the
shows that only 5% of many plastic
surgery with half succumb have the
higher so he's using the 5% survival as
a nation obsessed answer them all and
we'll go over this book
so please answer each question quickly
thank you for answering them
this is your last question
okay we can look at the results of the
poll
so do you perform survival surgery in
rodents we have a 72 percent response
great a lot of people do bowel surgery
in ruins okay let's look at the next
question
if you perform survival surgery in
rodents are you very confident that you
follow strict aseptic technique okay 73
percent has answered yes okay good thank
you do you conduct rotten surgery
training or responsible for such
training at your institution so we have
a 63% yes and the next question and last
question is if so how well do your
investigators apply strict aseptic
technique 21% perform very well can we
go back on the last okay by 23% very
well 46% well and you can see pretty bad
six percent and well I kind of expected
these results because you think about it
these investigators most investigators
that do surgery and their labs
facilities they have not had adequate
training as I expect okay so the last
question is would you like to find easy
and practical ways to be able to conduct
each strict strict aseptic rodent
surgery in rodents very good thank you
very much for answering these questions
so after this meeting with this
investigator I became very frustrated
because we - we do have a potent story
survival surgery training program or
other institution this investigator and
the entire staff in his lab have gone
through the same a training that
everybody else goes through and I said
what's wrong
how come another prime since we went
through aseptic
rodent surgery what why do we do
we do wrong so I said things are gonna
have to change I have years look in the
internet and I've looked for materials
that help us that can help me illustrate
aseptic technique in rodents and an easy
way to do it
and again frustrated with my findings so
today our objectives will be to identify
and easily correct common mistakes that
lead to breaks and blood surgery is a
technique by the way this is not going
to be a presentation for stats graphs
statistics a lot of scientific data this
is a this is a presentation in which
will be sent to you we're gonna give you
materials that you can use for your
investigators and for yourself to apply
the technique we're gonna use practical
we're gonna explain practical uses of
Preston CO as a draping material which
is a grocery item and but it is packaged
sterile and we'll go over that in a
future slide
always remember that because it has a
sticky side the president/ceo it should
be placed towards the surface intended
to be draped and we will go over
practical uses of sterilized aluminum
foil as well so this presentation we're
gonna store number of slides where the
good will be indicated by this little
paint or smiley face and things that are
done wrong but this little guy called
the devil so first of all let's define
aseptic surgery not what if I talk about
why aseptic surgery you have all heard
it because I've heard him repeatedly the
runs don't get infected or if they can
in fact there's no big deal and so let's
talk about it a little bit so survival
alone is not a valid criterion remember
this investigator Jones that said that
five percent of his rats only five
percent motel
raid in his research well he was used in
survival as a criteria for success
however success
she'll be things not just in survival
but on the absence of altered
physiological functions immune responses
and behavioral changes which he had not
measured so a skeptic technique
increases the success of Bavarian
transplants in mice and speedy returned
to post-op state also when there's
contamination in the surgical field an
animal becomes contaminated surgery
macrophages are activated so macrophages
are activated all kinds of biochemical
neurological responses occur and the
animal and all these things lead to
variables in the research not to say
discomfort and animal welfare issues
contamination leads to changes to
install tines and B cells which again
affects the entire Mew system which
affects there will be another animal the
physiology of the animal and subclinical
infection so clinical infections are
those you may not see which in this
investigator himself may have not even
looked or seen them because that's a
clinical but so clinical factors do
exist and they produced they can produce
profound physiological changes in the
animal and therefore leads to variables
in the research so in this experiment by
John Brad field from alike international
hello John if you're watching this I'll
say hi to you that the in fact of these
animals rats with staph aureus and
Pseudomonas aeruginosa and they observed
no clinical signs in these animals
however these same animals with no
clinical signs in other words they only
have subclinical infection they saw
significant alterations and fibrinogen
and glucose and white blood cell counts
as well as histology scores lastly the
American College of laboratory animal
medicine was
system in rodent surgery stays that
aseptic technique is required for
survival surgery notice that a clam does
not differentiate in rodents and larger
species but aseptic surgery is required
in animals
regardless of the species because the
animals can develop either gross or
unapparent
or subclinical surgery inside infection
that may affect respect outcomes and
affect animal welfare so we're talking
about not only animal welfare but really
the welfare if you want to put it this
way of the data of the investigator math
is not always what it looks like in
theory there's no difference between
theory and practice by practice race so
today my goal is really to show you some
very easy to apply practical practical
and and convenient ways to apply aseptic
rodent surgery now can I say that I can
absolutely keep my animals 100%
contamination free it's not possible I
don't think it is possible or even
practical but by applying these
principles I think if even even though I
may not be applying in practice what I
teach 100% theory but I look for that
the implementation of everything that I
can to improve by my surgery result so
the goal is really not a total absence
of microorganisms because that's not
realistic the goal is to bring that
contamination below threshold in other
words to make it practical and to bring
those levels as low as possible it is it
has been said that it takes an enormous
animal it takes approximately 1 million
infection particles per gram of tissue
to overwhelm the immune system so if we
can bring these levels as far down as we
can I think
nuwell of course
a normal animal but what about an
immunocompromised animal if you really
need to follow aseptic technique with
normal animals how much more should you
do it with immunes our immune
compromised so the adage that says the
solution to pollution is dilution plays
very well here when it comes to
expecting button surgery again we wanted
the news bug to the lowest possible
levels without the expectation that
there will be a total absence of
microorganisms it's not realistic so
today those tips and tips and many tips
so look here this this picture now you
know make from your introduction thank
you again Mitch for the nice
introduction
what's wrong just think I'll think about
this what's wrong with this picture
okay think about it look at it you see
this is a surgery table right there what
is he doing at the surgery table he's
flipping the animal
what does those hair where does hair go
when you clip sort of spreads it becomes
airborne the dander becomes airborne
infectious particles and all that and
what does gravity do whatever it goes up
it goes down to right so we need to be
very careful what we do where we prep
the animals so we're gonna give this a
bad face mate we have to open this which
makes did right here you can see that
Mitch has moved away from the surgery
table so he can clip the animals away
from the surgery tables so he is
counting on on a separation in the lab
to be able to minimize contamination
right there where the surgery table is
I'm better yet an improvement to this
will even be you could clip the animals
and prep the animals away from the
surgery table or actually from there
from another so we are going to get this
face okay so why don't we just look at
this video and we want to give you
samples of the videos where we have
reduced the main visualization of its
principles very easy particular video
using present steel which I know that in
some countries you may not find it
I hope hopefully you do I remember I
when I went to do presentation we
presented clearly back in I think it was
2014 and I was told that percent co2 not
be found
the first grocery store that I went to
low and behold there they have presence
here you can compromise as you may be
able to use other materials like cling
wrap and saran wrap but they don't have
the stickiness that person still have so
let's move this video forward
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the file
okay so the video did not play so I
would like to add another presentation I
have a link to all these very Jewish
produce and number of videos of organic
we're going to keep producing these
videos on apologize I don't know why
they are not playing right here in this
video we were intending to show you a
very easy method of of raping the table
in that table but presence here what I
having to use I said the technique very
easy a lot of individuals a lot of
investigators will place will have
sterilized tiny surface of something
like that and they get all kinds of
cross-contamination because they have an
extended the sterile field so I'm gonna
go into the next slide we have a total 5
5 video hopefully the other ones will
play right here and this in this picture
I would like you to think about what's
wrong here so this is a sterile side and
then we have the nah sterile side we
typically like to or many times we like
to Billy have tape or some indicator
where this feral side of the table
starts where it ends so what's wrong
with this picture
what's wrong with this okay hopefully
you all saw it
look at these instruments that have
crossed the sterile field into from the
sterile field into the non sterile field
so we're gonna give this demo face what
about this one here look mister outside
it's on the left everything is there
where it needs to be we're gonna give
this a face okay so hopefully this video
will play now and we are going to show
you here how to play sterile instruments
and supplies in the sterile field with
that touching a sterile field without
cross-contamination hopefully this one
will play we'll give it a try
[Music]
hopeful I'm sorry they're in a plane
it's okay but at least it will be
available to you okay so we'll go into
the next slide and we'll discuss the
skin prep so the skin prep was another
area of a lot of frustration for a lot
of people a lot of investigators using
the wrong solution there bonk rubber so
let's just look at it first of all
remove hair when you do a skin scrubbing
in preparation for surgery typically
most people use for hexa diene or hold
on iodine scrub followed by 70 percent
alcohol so keep in mind that look at
this right here we were talking about
scrub not solution so let's go on the
next next you have to do the scrub all
over alcohol you're gonna do at least
two more times but then after the those
three applications your last after your
last alcohol application you're gonna
paint all right
that's gross why am I saying these
things you how many of you have ever
made hamburger patties yeah most of you
have made some hamburger patties at some
point like so when you make hamburger
patties do you just move your hands what
do you do you place your hands under the
water faucet hopefully that someday like
Greece would be removed from your hands
now what you do you're gonna use stroke
exactly well if is the hexa diene
solution which is you know really water
soluble if I use it as my scrubbing
solution only the exiting or buried or
nitrogen then I'm not going to be
removing some of the grease and some of
the oils and debris that are on the skin
it's very nothing of course that's why
you apply scrub to begin with is really
the detergent it is a soap so I in this
dr.jones
lab the way they did the skin scrubbing
was with a little pad once but with
bok-dong iodine solution so we corrected
that in that lab as well once you have
done your laps application in other
words your chlorhexidine you know
povidone iodine solution you are like
that to try it on you can probably put a
colony of bacteria in a solution of
betadine or or chlorhexidine and it may
take I don't know maybe five six seven I
don't know how many hours it would take
to really kill all the microorganisms
but you are like that same solution to
dry on and then there is the instant
killing so the secret here is you allow
the solution before you you make your
incision a lot of solution to dry on the
skin because it is the combination of
the chemical activity and desiccation
desiccating activity that is solely to
bacteria now we have another video which
I don't think it's gonna play with
because it is hard to follow all these
words and and the video illustrate quite
nicely the the process that we just
described here because a picture in this
case video is worth not a problem
million words so we don't think this is
gonna play but I think we may have to go
into the next time again we apologize
for this we're very disappointed it's
not playing but keep in mind here that
when you do your when you do your
scrubbing used to go as it will be
described in the under video you go from
the center and you break it away to the
periphery many people will do the
periphery go back to the center
and they recontaminate the surgical
field so again from the center to the
periphery we're going to the next slide
so draping the animal every animal
should be draped in fact remember the
story the animals individual was doing
surgery and the head was not draped many
of the sailors to say it is doing
convenient to drive the head well I
think it can be done it can be done very
easily and it needs to be done in just
about every surgical procedure but what
constitutes the ideal treatment material
the field record material should be one
that hears the skin so it doesn't move
around yeah that way you don't bring the
nation from the periphery back to the
center of the surgical field to be
impermeable to moisture because if you
use something that is permeable as the
trigger material then when things get
what their is waking the bacteria from
the periphery to the center and they
have potential contamination it should
be transparent it happens that when you
are involved
institutions in particular just hard to
guess you've ever seen an industry where
you are you know how you are the surgeon
you are the nurse you are the the
anesthetist and you are a golfer and you
need to you you need to be able to see
you need to be able to monitor the end
of the respiration the respiration rate
there's respiration character you want
to take the cover of this game all the
things so there deal driven materials to
be transparent and also should track
body heat hypothermia it's detrimental
to officially I don't recover the animal
and this is for another discussion which
we have time to talk about the problems
with hypothermia in the animals all
animals should be in a state of normal
thermia through our surgery and the
recovery period pasta and
that should be warmed up the ideal
driving material traps body heat may
give an example of a material that is
I've seen it in fact I'll admit it
early on many years ago I have used it
as my draping material it's a 4x4 car
yeah it's better than nothing but look
at this right here the animal gets wet
and it is waking from the periphery
because it's material and a lot of
people will use these darkness these
studies are rolls of cotton material
that that ultimate urgent or the doctor
will put on your arm before he puts a
cast on so the cactus and I here - your
skin it is a practical material that can
be rolled it sterilized autoclave and
rolled over the animal and to cover the
animal completely I've seen you use I
have used in the past a lot made it but
it is a con material we would like to
discourage you from from using it so
let's talk about press and seal okay so
again press and seal is a grocery item
and it's sterile now you think Marcel
you are out of your mind
how can you use a grocery item as a
surgical drape well let's look at it
logically first one is if see that piece
of meat right there and the box if you
know what to wrap a piece of meat or
your hamburger or whatever it is that
you're wrapping and you place it in your
refrigerator and if the person seal is
contaminated and they get surprised do
you think this company would be in
business today I don't think so so by
logic the person has to be here but
again my I do not accept that I don't
think any I go to accept it without any
some some proof because this is not a
veterinary item and so what do we do we
culture we have culture presents deal
number times we continue to do quarterly
yes just in case but 110 of our cultures
have come back negative with zero growth
so an addition present zero you can
adhere to the skin because it has a
sticky surface its impermeable to
moisture it's plastic it's transparent
that allows you to monitor the animal
and they trans body heat in fact that
one time we were working with present
CEO in fact not only that we were
producing some of these videos that
unfortunately you are not able to see
and [ __ ] start to wrap person seal a
couple layers around his leg and and he
said myself Fridays see how it wraps Eid
I remember even did it myself but Rabb
the presidency around my thigh and felt
heat been hotter hotter my leg get
harder it's because trapped heat now you
see this item on the left the widget I
have used many times that drape I think
it's a questionable drape because first
of all in order to keep it in place you
have to use Babcock for spam so
sometimes that pierce the skin and it's
a little bit of drama on that maybe not
a whole lot it is material that in you
can't see the animal and I'm not sure it
is impermeable and really I I lost that
ability to really look at this and look
at the respiration the rate of the
character to monitor the animal so we go
in favor of press and seal not only is a
great but you will see striped not only
for the animal you've already seen it
before for the table to extend your your
sterile field and all the items to which
we will show you in a few minutes
look at this picture this is a great
picture that I have received from
Charles River give credit to that Thank
You Charles River and this animal right
here it is something going
surgery on the neck right there on the
throat is the categorization of the
jugular vein and that jugular vein is
going to be on under the skin and be
brought out between the shoulder blades
here so if you only had one surface
where the animal is great when you turn
the animal around you're gonna have some
contaminator of some type
well solution here would be to place the
presence of sticky sides fit in each
other facing the animal and when you
turn the animal lo and behold you have
you have maintained this ability and you
have avoided cross-contamination would
like to bring your attention to the tail
the tail should always be incorporated
as much as possible
and on the drape and the particular boat
the plastic drape and also it should be
laying on and then you'll see that in a
picture and in a few moments it should
be incorporated into the heating pad
because the hell is where rodents lose a
lot of heat and if you protect if you
keep the animal from losing heat through
the tail you're really doing enough or
to maintain the animal form normal
thermic right here is another picture
look at it everything is in place in the
sterile field look at the tail is
incorporated into the animal and it's
under the present seal so it is a smiley
face there you go
unfortunately we won't be able to play
this video and we again will point you
to our website where you'll be able to
visualize all these videos you can do
videos and you can you can pause and
look at them and I'm going to go into
the next slide
so here's Mitch okay
you know these things some of these
things that we're gonna be looking at
now they're quite obvious okay it is
pretty obvious what's wrong here however
a lot of all these slides I'm gonna
present to you although it may seem
obvious to you it's what we see in these
animal facilities and with these
investigators in particular so what's
wrong with this with this picture with
this image I think you know it okay you
did not use any hair cover okay he is
likely to particles to fall right on the
surgical field and contaminate this one
devil face what's wrong with this
picture again may be obvious to you see
it all in time with our investigators
look at that okay so you know the
problem is is they're using a gown or a
lab coat okay so all right now again I
see this repeatedly Oh
Trainor other institutions that I only
see at my institution and these are only
things and along with my experience dr.
Jones and actually Mitch was involved in
that experience do that has let let us
and prefer wrong surgery the training
program I went to the University of
Madison thank you John University of
Wisconsin for helping me after the train
which is fantastic I we made another
video to illustrate these things and not
only just for my investigators but
because I was so frustrated and the lack
of materials aren't there in the
internet on the performance of ron
stovall surgery in an aseptic matter
that we may we bolted all these videos
and handouts numerous handouts and to
our website
available to the public all over the
world so you're walking to any of them
any time so what's wrong here you
already can see it he's using nine
pounds lost and we'll give him an elbow
love should be sterile if you use
sterile surgical gloves unless you can
confirm that you can sterilize or or
have use non surgical gloves are sterile
so why don't we just do a quick little
practice I'm gonna give you a few
minutes okay so what we're gonna do
there are many Devils on the step on
this this picture look at them they're
about ten Devils that I can police
identify you might be able to identify
more than that let me give you about a
minute of silence and let you look
through it identify look at the person
look at the table items on the table
look to see areas were contamination
cross contamination has happened or that
we have contaminated the sterile field
or sir early sterile surgical table wait
for a minute
you seen them okay well why don't we
just identify them and I'll give you
just a couple more seconds to look at it
and then we're going to go ahead and
look at them okay so number one
obviously Laurie's not wearing her cover
of any kind look what she and this is
what I saw in that lab dr. Jones she's
touching her contaminated glass assists
with her gloves and I saw them during
the surgery and by the way this
investigator also claimed I had an
excellent surgery program yeah these are
the results of all those things that I
saw boss look can you see number four
there's the rich packaged syringe
packages I'm not the inside of the
package might be sterile and down me
going me there's contamination again
look up here number six that's suture
package again the internal parts inside
of the this back of suit your back
it is sterile but not the outer package
look great on them
the staple of outer package you see that
again the gloves the internal contents
of this package may be sterile or to be
sterile the outer package is not you see
that right up to their sterile last
lease the disinfectant bottle number 10
the sterile field so very very clear
right logic anybody could have not only
my institutions other institutions were
perform training and thus make a reason
why our program has to be restructure of
training has been restructured and why
we posted all these presentations these
handouts powerpoints were documents and
in particular videos on our website for
our ears and your use so right here look
at these you know you're supposed to
work get on some time and but in
addition to that even though they not
require that were pleased plastics
please we think they're stupid they
should be sprayed with disinfectant in
fact there are some detected out there
that claim they are sterilized and why
do we do that
ok it will become obvious in just a
minute we'll go over that in just a
minute
again this is a video on how to properly
on sterile gloves we'll leave that for
the near future when you go into a
website so what is the big part personal
protective equipment for individuals
doing rotten survival surgery one he
should be wearing aghanim's lab coat
sterile gloves
I think it's mask hair cover and even
though again the ops leaves are not
mentioned in the guard we believe they
should be required they should be this
why do I say that it's because look at
this right here
Mitch and you see that in another
picture mitch is not just working here
but he mooses know not working right
there but he's moving his arms back and
forth he'll be moving his arms to pick
pick up materials here he'll be moving
his arms back up worth all over the
place and in the process of doing that
the sleeps of his lab coat if he didn't
have at least minimize the contamination
by using these very inexpensive plastic
sleeves spread with this in fact they
were sterilant and then he's less likely
to contaminate the the field so again
the solo surgeon once again the same
person in particular when it comes to
the rotten surgery stirs as the road
surgeon the anesthetist surgical
technician scrubbed Norton and they go
fer this is the problem because
cross-contamination is rampant in these
scenarios so what happens if you are the
source version and you have too many
plate ups of the stereotaxic apparatus
or the anesthesia dials or something
like that
surgery there you go now you you see you
have to make those adjustments and you
have gloves stop the next slice provide
a solution for the sole surgeon look at
this run here what is Mitch doing okay
he has sterile gloves and he's touching
the on the life he's touching it down to
the oxygen flow and he is touching the
anesthesia the vaporizer
isoflurane vaporizer he has to just
deepen the animal to light the animal
with sterile gloves that's a problem so
why don't we just use either person
steel or aluminum sterilized
autoclave aluminum foil now you notice I
said press and seal and then use the
word sterilized alumina
for the reason of say sterilized or
autoclave aluminum for it because
presence here we have we already proven
that it comes sterile and there's only
one presence here that I'm aware of
a little foil there are a number
although I'm pretty much who think I'm I
can almost assure you that every
aluminum foil sold in the supermarket at
a grocery store out there comes sterile
but I cannot prove it because for us to
prove it we have to stick to one brand
and test that over and over and over
again so we can prove our I cook that
particular brand is sterile but there
are many brands so which one do you use
well we it happens that we are about to
start purchasing a particular brand that
we will be using that brand and a brand
alone and we're going to test it so stay
tuned for the future so lots of smiley
faces what about their taxes apparatus
any of you who use who do the us
stereotactic surgery knows that you're
constantly constantly surgery they're
moving the knobs you're adjusting to the
right to the left you have to if you're
gonna be going in the brain you have to
you have an electrode and I like growth
it has to be taken to a certain depth
then you have to do that adjustment and
move the knobs and all that so if you're
using sterile gloves it's what you just
contaminated your gloves but why not put
prices heel or aluminum for other
players again looking for on these knobs
cross-contamination by the way I need to
say something about presence here at the
repeat applications of presence it's a
sticky surface what times you're gonna
feel that there's there's a sticky
residue on the surfaces where you have
placed like particular knobs and things
like that where you place the presence
you well
that can easily be removed with 4x4
gulfs and alcohol so smiley faces here
what about the line many times I need to
guess alight the position of the light
because my hands the surgical wound may
cast a shadow on the wound so I need to
move the light to continue to visualize
my sterile field or my surgical work so
again here you have some solutions
practical solutions and then the
microscope this is our microscope
surgical microscope of work the same
thing we do with either present zero
aluminum foil and this is I was
evaluated a surgical program and
investigate almost having infections or
another institution that will not say
where and even when I we have to go with
these all these issues of present sealed
how to maintain sterility what I you
seen that we're not using sterile field
they were not raping the animal so after
we went through this training I go back
to look after T Halle we're doing so
they were used in this case saran wrap a
present sealed and I I saw this and I
was impressed because this particular
certain they had to do time injections
and a such she needed primer not if you
touch the timer guess what Renee you're
lost but she was very creative I love
what she did she just cover her iPhone
and very easy solution the same way in
individual a use cling wrap to wrap the
pen because she had red noses results of
her findings during surgery so I see was
this again I apologize I wish you could
have seen the videos but you will have
access to them can you now that if I
come a mistakes lead to breaks and
aseptic technique
think you do now do you now have easy to
apply skills and you will be able to I
believe do you not have the new tools to
improve your programs in particular if
you do training to program to improve
your programs aseptic technique I think
you do so
here finishing up I'm going to refer you
to a website here's on top a short URL
and bottom there are long URL but there
we have not a lot of material but before
we do that this is where those links
will lead to do and this page goes down
and down because we have all kinds of
material for you on surgery anesthesia
on bio methodology techniques and mice
and rats we have actually even now some
showed you how to diagnose breathing
problems and we have all the videos that
I've been mentioning here and you can
see here and we will continue to
populate this site with more videos and
these handouts are are updated as new
information comes on so use it to your
advantage
we even have guidance here and if you're
doing a particular surgical technique if
it produces mild moderate or severe pain
well we give you suggestions on the type
of analgesia protocol that you should
use on these animals so thank you very
much for attending this and we welcome
your questions so thank you dr. Perez
presentation and a quick reminder to our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and more so with many questions time
permitting some up we've had quite a bit
again sorry for the technical
difficulties we apologize for that
so let's get started here so when I
saved was okay so the first one question
I have here is from Linda Walla this
apologize if I butchered your name but
she's from Wayne State University the
question is are there any abstracts
available which speaks to the use of
presence ill-assorted rape we actually
published last year a very short little
technical advice paper and and story
savvy but I'll be glad to send this to
you for anyone who requests it a next
question is from Ulysses orchard from
Rice University the question is I know
you have advocated the use of Preston
steel in the past but I have concerns
that advocates the use by other
veterinarians do due to the high volume
of surgery is it still a good drape to
use if you're if you're talking about
private practice I don't know if you're
talking about private practice or not
but I have had private practitioners
have contacted me asking me about it I
said go for it you can actually you can
get repeat overlapping and I wish again
you could have seen the video where we
do that on the table but you can see
overlapping sheets you can actually
apply overlapping sheets of resin seal
and use it as a very expensive in fact
drape for your animals not sure if I
answer that it's that what you
understood - okay and also that all
these videos were talking about the
links he shows the next question is from
Trish Lindsey from the University of
Calgary the question is when using press
and seal
I presume it will be placed with robust
how can it be placed terribly and how
would recommend to wreak love one
straight at that place
let me refer you to all videos where we
illustrate that there is a method of
doing this in a non sterile way and
you'll be surprised again it was one of
the videos 10% today but you can watch
him online through our website and also
we show you how to do it with their
clothes as well and another question
from Andrew he asks can the surgeon
grasp the present from the container if
he doesn't pull it out well with the
sterile gloves and then can those blood
still be considered sterile you can pull
it yes I will refer you again to a video
that is well illustrated in our videos
so we actually we have to tie so we've
shown videos with assistive way to pull
out the person seal and keep your
sterility and also we have a solo
surgeon the next question is from Lisa
Wilberforce I hope that correctly from
Queens University the question is how
could you use Preston seal for
stereotactic surgery once again we have
we have illustrations we have one hand
out in our website where it shows you
how to do this in a very practical
manner
please go to our handouts this this
question is addressed on leaf the title
the presentation is is used in person
CEO or something like that
for stereotactic surgery and it's
reiterate because a lot of these
questions commands with videos the
information that we share information
we're always happy to answer questions
and to help you guys do things so if you
have problems the videos just email us
we'll get back to you
yeah you can actually email match as
well and I think I give you his
information but you can email me and we
can the two of us we can answer a lot of
your quick
there's a couple questions I'm going to
kind of time all together it's asking if
your animals on a heating pad that the
press'n seal interfere with keep warm
actually it helps maintaining the animal
warm because remember what we talked
about earlier in the presentation
persons do be in a plastic material is
almost like a windbreaker when you wear
a windbreaker it traps the heat and it
actually helps me in normal thermia and
so they go with that
is there any chance overheat we advocate
always to maintain the animals normal
thermic but keep track of temperature
you should have a thermometer there are
systems out there they use a system that
give you feedback and you should be able
to see it on a monitor
yeah you should keep track of the
temperature you should be able to
maintain normal thermia and systems
therefore it can for example can
Scientifics systems like the official
suite they give you feedback and when
the temperature goes high the homeo
thermic blanket pad turns to off and if
the temperature goes down the thermic
pad goes up so yes it maintains no
pithre mean exactly you should monitor
temperature thank you sir and another
question is this is more about surgeries
and instruments the questions from
alcohol brain in between multiple
surgeries what are your thoughts on this
practice well we have in our one of our
PowerPoint presentations we discuss this
in quite a bit of detail
and alcohol itself she is not considered
sterile and a prolonged use of it may be
a lacks position on the use of alcohol
it's a tsunami considered we are but if
you initially autoclave use instruments
and then you place between surgeries and
alcohol and you use a heartbeat
sterilizer and between to sterilize the
tips of your instruments we we recommend
that we think there's okay we limit this
to the instruments to up to five
surgeries with initially autoclave set
of instruments because beyond that and
there's a publication of there has shown
beyond that the micro Burton goes up
significantly thank you sir it looks
like I wanted to thank today for all the
interesting questions very good
questions for the questions we have time
for content information that we provided
in this presentation and well thank you
very much everyone or you may be the
world we're pleased and honored that you
attended this session I hope you found
it helpful you can contact me anytime
I'm available and I don't respond right
away I will respond eventually and one
more videos after this so thank you
thank you everybody thank you